[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm
rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting we
are reminiscing was like
yeah that's like you know that old song
i know there's a song reminiscing
but i don't quite remember the tune
right now you might get in trouble
singing it anyway
yeah so i just bailed i don't want to
get kicked i made up a new song
reminiscing
[Music]
about what is it oh our most memorable
meal
what is it i almost forgot is that a
joke that is uh irony
for you ironclad irony
uh yeah what are your most memorable
meals and
what are our most memorable meals and
i'm sure
hearing from them dang i keep hearing
from them and reminiscing
about about their most memorable meals
will make us remember more meals that
are maybe more memorable more ones that
i have remembered
in advance of this yes uh
i do want to say that um
we want to give you a heads up about
next week's and the next week's
episodes of your biscuits because we are
doing what we're calling our
deconstruction stories
one year later and we're each gonna get
an episode because hey we each got an
episode before to tell our story so this
is going to be
where are we at in the process and
whatever we want to say one year later
from from each one of us so if that
subject matter
uh intrigues you it's like an annual
dose of spirituality
well i'd like to think you get more than
just an annual dose yeah we can pepper
it in
yeah but it will be sort of the like
let it all hang out spiritually speaking
uh and tell you where we're at um but
yeah so i wanted to start just by asking
you
do you remember what you had for dinner
last night
i just found something in the corner of
my eye and i'm not gonna eat that
no has that been there all day i mean
you know you wear glasses you don't have
to worry about eye crusties and stuff i
have to scrape
eye crusties out of like the corner of
jade's eyes like
get kind of weeps down her nose oh yeah
well for those of you don't know that's
my wife
no that's my dog um and then
she likes to eat it i'm not saying that
i feed it to her
i think but are saying that i'm saying
that she if she eats it then that means
that you you took it off and you put it
somewhere when she let her eat it
like in her mouth yeah yeah i did yeah
you're admitting that i don't think
there's anything wrong with it but
she wants to eat it i know she wants to
eat it because she the moment i get it
out of her eye like she's like
scrambling to eat it god
man why don't you just lick her own eyes
but
i have to admit that i've just resorted
to just
feeding it that's horrible isn't it
this isn't the way i wanted to start a
most memorable meal i was asking you
what you
ate last night
oh man i regret i regret uh every time i
do it i regret it
but i regret even more sharing that but
you know
this is a safe space not anymore oh
gosh what do i remember what
do you remember what you ate last night
you don't remember my question um
yes i do it took a second
but i ate a baked fish dish a baked fish
dish
yeah the reason why i i was like wow of
course i remember this is because
christy was i was like what's for dinner
and christie was like i'm making some
fish i'm like what we we
don't do we don't really what we don't
eat that much fish at home
because you got to fig you know you got
to figure out how to prepare it it's
like
can i figure it out man chicken is so
easy and so many options
i don't know who am i to say anyway you
don't you wouldn't know how to cook
fish chicken regardless it's not
she made she made some uh a baked fish
dish
do you know what kind of fish it was uh
i think it was a rock fish
it was a white flaky fish um
i really i mean you didn't ask this but
you didn't i was really torn if i was
going to tell her what i thought of it
i didn't i'll just talk about it on this
podcast
well i did say you know we found this
fish place that we ordered lunch from
and i really like it and they make this
fish and it's
they put cajun seasoning on it sometimes
garlic butter i know garlic butter is
not good for you but
that's a really good combination having
both of those or just the cajun
seasoning
and i left it at that what would you
you just wanted to take it and run with
it and that was basically my way of
saying
that fish should make a restaurant style
that fish is better than the fish he
made oh no okay i got what you're saying
which was like
it had onions and like lime and
it didn't it didn't really come together
and i was like did you bake it
or saute it she was like i baked it i
was like
well you could you know you could saute
it i don't think
i don't think you know what's going to
make it good i don't but
i was trying to come up with a
constructive
and subtle way to say i didn't like it
well i did i wasn't really expecting us
to get into
this level of analysis i was just going
to ask you you don't like something that
christie
christie she makes meals for me all the
time i mean jesse
um do you just tell her because yeah no
no i just told you no
we we we um it's delicious i don't know
uh
cause who am i what it i'm not a cooker
well see i am right
so i i make i make a quite a few meals
at our house not as many as jessie but
it's getting it's getting pretty close
in something to some degree but
um there is this moment of sort of
critique when we're eating when we start
eating something like and i if
i made something like so last night i
made
pork chops just well i made pork chops
on the grill and jesse made
um some like cauliflower and something
else on the side
and it's like when we sit down i'm like
all right what are you like what do you
think and i'm like i think i may have
overcooked these a little bit like
there's a there's a and then she and
then jesse's like i don't know maybe i
should start doing a different seasoning
on the cauliflower like we have a moment
of analysis and sort of like critical
analysis around what we've made and
that's pretty common it does get kind of
demoralizing
because our kids are
pretty picky um and the nature of the
conversation
is not anything like what we would have
had in my house growing up
you didn't tell so do they get on the
critique is that what you're saying
they do yeah my kids are smart enough to
stay quiet when i said that of course
lincoln didn't eat fish at all he had
chicken nuggets
okay well that was an insult but no my
kids will do that they'll opt out of a
dish altogether there was no opting out
for us i mean you ate what your mama
gave you
uh but anyway the thing is
is that if i hadn't have asked you to
think about that meal that you had last
night
and and i hadn't thought about the meal
that i had last night
i would forget about it you know what
i'm saying i there i'm there
might be no other time in my life when i
would stop and think about the meal last
night there was nothing remarkable
about the food and there was nothing
remarkable
about the setting and the circumstances
because it's interesting as you start
looking at people's most memorable meals
it's definitely there's not one thing in
common there's a
bunch of different sets of factors that
can determine
something being this meal is going to
stick with me
for the rest of my life it's kind of
fascinating
yeah so we're going to get into what you
said are your most memorable meals thank
you for responding
you know we make the post on our twitter
account at mythical
we do that a lot if you want to be
recognized get a shout out
dictate the conversation to an ear
biscuit follow us on
our twitter account at mythical uh we do
i mean
a week won't go by where there's some
question that we're trying we won't go
by and we won't let we won't let it
go we're trying to we're trying to put
out there i mean the fish i would have
remembered
i think i'm more likely to remember
because we eat so we don't eat much fish
and it wasn't that great if i said that
but um it's kind of interesting yeah
most meals just kind of blow by
because you've got it you know on
average three a day
unless you're a hobbit and they just
kind of they just kind of wash
over you um but let let's just
let's get to one here this one um is
from
a 2237 webb and elise
my cousins and i went to yellowstone
when i was young
we bought a frozen stouffer's mac and
cheese and put it directly in the fire
to cook it
i could see how you could do that
because it's
you know it's um that aluminum
pan you just throw it right in the fire
uh
it was repulsive half cold and tasted
like
ash i said ash
yeah be clear and the fact that we all
got sick later in the trip
may have not been a coincidence
yeah the old so bad you can't forget it
meal yeah um one thing usually when
you're camping
everything yeah everything tastes better
one thing i will note about this
is this the last sentence we all got
sick later in the trip that may not have
been a coincidence
um i don't know i don't remember what
the context was i was listening to
a uh someone who specializes in
foodborne illnesses like they were on a
video or a guest on a podcast or
something
and the woman was saying it cracks me up
how often anyone who has some sort of
what some sort of sickness mm-hmm they
always think they know where it came
from
yeah they're like i had some bad sushi
last night or da da da da and she
and she's basically like you have no way
of knowing
but what happens is is when something
you get sick after a meal you think in
your
sleuthing skills you know exactly what
caused it and then it turns you against
that food for a certain amount of time
maybe the rest of your life
her point was is people are almost
always incorrect about that assumption
because she said that for instance one
of the most common things
is that there was a food handling
mistake like you didn't realize that
there was a little bit of salmonella on
your cutting board when you cut those
vegetables for the salad or something
like that
and it takes about it could take
anywhere from like 24 hours to 72 hours
for that to manifest itself
and she's like the window of time
between inciting event and
your the purge that the body goes
through
is so variable that people just don't
know but yet
you associate everyone always thinks
it's that oh i know exactly what meal it
was
why and i think saying food poisoning
is kind of shorthand
of like yeah i was i was sick i was
almost to like a debilitat like i
couldn't have i couldn't come to work or
i couldn't make it to this thing
so it's a valid excuse but then also
it's
reassuring when when that person is
talking to you
is that well it was because of food i
ate i'm not contagious
so it's it's just kind of a it's a it's
a shorthand to get to both of those
i also think another reason people do it
is because you know not to get graphic
but if you vomit up that ham sandwich
you eat at hearties
when you were nine years old and you
which is what happened to me and i can't
eat
roast beef at hardee's anymore which
it's been tough to navigate that one my
entire life i'll tell you
roast beef at heart yes yeah it was like
an artillery thing
i don't know an arby's or no out of
hardee's little hearties
carl jr uh but when you you know
when you up chuck a meal you think the
meal calls and you're starting to
and you're looking at it it's an
association thing then you're like
that's gross
you know i bet that's what that's what
came up that must be what my body had
rejected because it it was the source of
it of course that's not
that's not how it works no right because
i think that that is the principle that
your body's working on but
it was probably something that you ate
in a previous meal and it's saying i'm
getting rid of everything including what
you just ate
and you're just being like well i'm
gonna connect the dots and people
almost always associate it with
a food experience that they weren't
controlling so
people almost always say what was that
restaurant i went to or was that takeout
that i got but it definitely wasn't the
sandwich that i made for myself
you know what i'm saying like you don't
want to take responsibility for it well
it's probably the thing you did
it might be bad sushi who knows but you
don't know and you should probably just
try not to it's such an expedient
ex explanation this is going to change
my behavior
well i'm just saying next time you get
sick and you think it's food poisoning
just resist the urge to tie it to one
particular meal because
you don't want to ruin a food for
yourself if you don't have to
like i don't know if annelise now
doesn't eat
mac and cheese or if she just doesn't
eat mac and cheese that's cooked over a
fire which
that whole thing trying to cook over a
fire and not
getting the fire down low enough and so
you've got like
ash going into it i've made that mistake
a few times i mean i
most memorable camping story i think
that
that this triggers for me is the one
time we went to
summer camp yeah and that's where we
learned about hobo
burgers where you you put the
ground beef and potatoes potatoes
onions some barbecue sauce i seem to
remember carrots
carrots were in their first time for
sure and um barbecue sauce and then you
you you make a pocket and then you wrap
up the third thing and you
seal it tight and then it blows up like
a balloon when you put it down in the
ashes and if yours doesn't blow up like
a balloon you made a mistake in the
rolling
that's right yes that's on you it's on
you and it was just like
one more thing that was an entirely new
experience that we ended up doing many
times while camping
that's right afterwards yeah haven't
done that with the kids we talked to the
kids about that on the death valley trip
but we didn't actually do it
yeah because it does require a little
more work you got to get
you got it's got to go down to ash
yeah to just the coals to work ideally
all right here's another one uh from
the real eight whoop
on twitter my parents had eight children
including me
okay wow i am number six
mom made spaghetti for dinner mom left
the room
dad took plain piece of spaghetti and
twirled it over his head like a lasso
okay all us kids laughed and started
twirling spaghetti over our heads
ours had sauce mom came back oh end of
story
that's it that's a good that's a
well-constructed tweet i
dwoo you know i get painted a picture
spaghetti sauce everywhere of course
it's dad's fault
this is like always this is like
something that happens in a movie or
a book this isn't something that happens
in
in real life is it i guess i mean when
you have that many kids
something's always happening you know
it's i mean
with three kids there's there's there's
always something
there's always a fire to put out
sometimes literally i've only got
two and the amount of things that get
broken
and and i just you know
i just don't think my family's built for
more children i think those
those families that have a lot of kids
like there they made an observation
about the first one
and then the second one and then the
third one they were like okay we can
manage this
we made observations about our children
and we're like did we make a mistake
christy counts me as one of the children
and i can't argue with that
but you know i mean talking about a
family memory
happening over meal time i mean
i as i was racking my brain for my most
memorable meals one of the first things
that came to my mind was
you know it's it's not so much the one
meal
as gathering around the same table like
i can picture the table
that i that my mom had that the two of
us grew up around you know it was
um we would sit down and have a lot of
meals together
it wasn't you know she might have only
made
five or so dishes and then rotated them
but we would all sit down at that
you know that wooden table i actually
think
it was the table with jimmy
and emmy too like so the four of us have
family gathered around that table
and then when the divorce happened we
took that table with us jack
but you know it's i'm glad that as a
family we still
have this expectation that we're gonna
try to have meals
around the table and a lot of times it's
like well let's just sit around the
television
there's something going on let's let's
watch something or
or eat separately or whatever but i mean
that's when
it's not so much the specific memories
as it is just the
general memory of having a place that
you gather and that's important
but the i think just as
memorable to me and special to me is
growing up
every other sunday after church
we would go to my nanny's house so my
mom's mom
this is the one my grandma that passed
away
this past summer and i wasn't able to go
home um
and and one of the you know when i was
just thinking about all my fond memories
of her
just her fried chicken like my favorite
fried chicken i've ever eaten
did you do fried chicken every time
pretty much every time like
one out of every four times it might be
like a pork roast or something else but
like
she knew how much i loved her fried
chicken and so she would
she would fry the neck bone
and i bet it might surprise you but i
would eat the neck bone
i would eat and i would eat that first
and then i would eat it's not a lot to
eat though
no eat the breading off of it i mean
it's i mean it's like that long it's a
lot longer than you think like the neck
bone
i mean how long is that four inches four
inches
i said i mean that's i wouldn't think a
chicken's not much longer than that
that's more than half of a chicken
is the neck it's longer than you think
the neck goes deep down in there
and there's a little bit of meat on it
it was kind of it's kind of nasty to
like be gnawing on this like
dinosaur-like neck but a miniature
dinosaur neck
it is kind of weird because i mean a lot
of kids are really
sensitive about identifying yeah
bones and like body parts and meat your
kids are like that
yeah yeah and i would move on to the
chicken leg and then the thigh
i would eat i'd eat a lot i'd eat all
the dark meat
i'd eat two thighs two legs and the neck
the neck is the dark meat
and um by the way i don't know if you
can hear it it's shaking our table but
the sound that was here last episode
it's back
they're just doing some work somewhere
and it like reverberates through the
ground and we're
trying to get it out of the uh the mix
so you may not hear it at all and then
what i just said is pointless but
just to acknowledge that but my most
memorable meals
i think that is like the most memorable
meal tradition
is all right we know we're going to
nannies after church
boy i remember when pastor rogers would
be like
droning on about his sermon
on about his sermon i would be picturing
that fried chicken man
you came didn't you you came i don't
think i ever i don't think i ever had
our fried chicken
or i guess i don't remember it if i did
huh i'm sure but you came over there
because you would ride the golf cart
together yeah but i don't think that was
a sunday afternoon thing
yeah i think it was other times like a
saturday or something it was a small
table there wasn't we'd bring in all the
chairs and it was i don't remember a
guest
i don't remember eating dinner over
there i think i would invite you to come
over afterward
i literally don't give a neck bone don't
give him the ass by the way
it's a capacity thing well because you
know my my all my family
extended family was in georgia um
so i've i've got some memorable meals
and one in particular i'll talk about in
a second but i didn't have the
you know i didn't have the regular going
to uh
grandma's house but i also do have a
story about grandma coming over
um that's right but first we wanted to
um
remind you about the mythical coloring
book you know we did this thing
we we partnered with uh is fan tunes
yeah
and uh put together basically brought
the world of mythicality the world of
mythical to life
well to life colorless life and now you
can bring it fully to life by coloring
it
and listen this is not for children i
mean i mean children can definitely
enjoy it there's nothing in there that's
offensive to children check that out
there's the ear biscuits
but uh this is for
basically stress relief for adults
of all ages adults of all ages get
yourself this coloring book
at mythical.com i see fans
mythical beasts posting uh completed
pages
and it's very impressive and relaxing
um while we're on the subject of family
so i i
and interestingly that interesting that
you mentioned fish
because um fish
i'll tell one of my fish stories but
fish actually is something that came to
mind
the first thing uh the first memorable
meal that i thought about
was at my aunt helen's house so
aunt helen it was my grandmother's uh
sister
and my grandmother mama nail helen she's
she's still around down in georgia she's
the one i talked about
uh her husband was gibbs patrick who had
the
the farm who incidentally when i said
that in the
in some one recent episode somebody
commented
i think i said it on good mythical more
somebody commented on youtube
i can't believe that your uncle was
gibbs i worked at the farm for years
really so small world but anyway they
had a pond
on the farm in a little lake house just
a little cabin that was on
the main pond there pond house it was a
pond house
and that's where we would stay when we
went to stay with them oh cool and
uh my favorite thing about the whole
deal was fishing so we
have cane poles and then corn
for baked and you would catch brim and
bass
maybe some crappy can't really remember
that
and just have this visceral
memory of catching the fish
cleaning the fish and all we did to
clean the fish was
cut the guts out like cut the belly take
the guts out and then
descale it yeah but they left the fins
on left the heads on left the tails on
gave it to aunt helen and she battered
those suckers up
and fried the fish whole and then we
would all go and sit around
this big plate of just whole
fish like i'm i'm going to put a whole
brim on my plate i'm going to put a
whole bass on my plate
yeah and um i just
it was so mind-blowing because it was
like we were just
like we were just catching these fish
like these fish were just happening in
the lake
fresh and now you did this thing to them
and now we're doing this thing to them
eating them
um you feel like a hunter-gatherer yeah
there's just something
you know deep
in your your dna that kind of connects
with that with the process of like
i took this from nature the immediacy of
survival processed it and put it in my
belly
in the context of the people that did
that with me and they are my family
like that's a it's a memorable you know
my friend you don't get that a lot you
know we don't get that
in everyday society yeah my papa neal he
would do fish fries like that
because he he'd freeze the fish and so
you know but by the time he would take
the boat out and we'd go fishing and
come back or whatever
he was typically uh too exhausted to
then have an actual a full-blown fish
fry but
we wait till another time you know okay
and then and i'm just gonna
just so i don't double back on this
another meal that came to mind was a
very similar thing
i think it was when we had gone to
santa cruz for the first summer project
and we in
in like locke had just been born like
right before that yeah
and uh we got back and jesse's family
was like hey we've rented
a houseboat for everybody to stay on and
now
we're talking a very i mean not a very
big boat and it was going to be
me and jesse and locke as a baby
and then jesse's sister and husband and
their two boys
jesse's parents and jesse's grandparents
both gaga and papa
sleeping on the sleeping on this
houseboat that was
anchored in the sound in between the
outer banks and the mainland and north
carolina
i was like this is nuts but i'm up for
it right
and um somehow the way it's kind of like
an rv we're like oh there's a bed here
kind of thing they've kind of worked it
out so that how i don't know how many
people that was but
maybe it doesn't everybody is sleeping
oh wow but they also
the the people who gave you let you rent
the houseboat gave you like a smaller
john boat with a motor on it to like
kind of go
around the sound with and me and my
brother-in-law chris
my father-in-law and papa went out
and we caught flounder uh
and of course you know flounder are
those fish that are really
like a dinner plate and they are their
eyes are on one side yeah they're
completely white
on the bottom and then they're like fish
colored on the top and both of their
eyes are on
because they just stay on the bottom so
crazy
and we caught a bunch of these flounder
took them back to the boat and my
brother-in-law
cooked them right as soon as we got back
he like sauteed them and i remember
that my mother-in-law had some sun-dried
tomatoes
and like olive oil or something and he
like cooked these things in
in that and then we ate it and i was
like
this is the best food i've ever had in
my life and it was again it was
something
but it was well if you work for it it
was the experience and it was the
freshness too
like taking something out of the water
and then within an hour
putting it in your mouth i mean it
doesn't get any better than that
so i highly recommend fresh fish
[Laughter]
jamie mitchell naragon
replied to us she said on a school trip
to germany
in the mid-90s we were led into a crypt
that apparently served
food sounds cool we never figured out
completely what we were eating but we
maintained
it was rat tail soup and some sweet pork
butt
then a kid lit his hair on fire yeah i
mean that makes for a memorable meal if
you're on a
a school trip and someone the hair on
the hair on fire is probably the
exclamation point on that memory that
caused it to never go away
i mean i i mean this this reminds me of
when we were in london and we you know
we were desperate to find a place to eat
and then pizza
where we got the chips oh we ate in an
old prison
yeah because it was an old prison and
they had like somehow
forced i mean it's like a bricked in
like cell that then there was in there
yeah they had taken the wall down so you
you would just
scoot scoot scoot scoot on either side
of this huge table
and we ordered uh we were basically
it was a bar designed to just go drink
but we were super hungry
he was like you have anything to eat he
was like um
i have some
mexican crisps
yeah so they were like the worst
tortilla chips we had ever had
but the best mexican crisps we had ever
had
i guess and the salsa was ketchup with
onions in it it was the best way to
describe it
i mean one of my best meals if you just
focus on the food and we've talked about
this before
and i mean this has to be in your top
five it's like
in london going to dishoom the indian
cuisine restaurant that was in my on my
list yeah when we went to vidcon london
uh and we performed and then we
we got reservations there we went there
with
uh our agent and stevie and jenna were
there too
and it was so good the food was so good
the drinks were so good i mean it was
just
i don't know it was it was amazing and
we
we we had to wait you know the that's
that's part of it
you know just having having to wait for
over an hour and have somebody wait in
line and
everyone else could walk around but then
someone had to stick around and
so there was this expectation that if
you can just walk right on to the roller
coaster oh it was pretty good
but you know if you if you've waited for
an hour and a half to get on that thing
it's it's more that's part of the
experience
for it to pay off so strong it was the
food was just so good and the hype
i i think rarely lived up to that well
but i think it depends on your
personality right so
i tend to believe the hype that i you
know
if you start hyping something up some
people are like
it probably isn't as good as he's making
it out to be and they kind of want to
contradict you yeah but i'm a i'm a
believe the hype go along with the hype
if somebody gets super excited about
introducing me to something
it makes it taste better to me right
because i because i do that to people
i i'm like hey i want you to enjoy this
right and that there's
and there was something part of the fun
of how much um
it had been talked up and i guess it was
brent who was like you got to go to this
place
i mean i can't either i can't remember
if he was like you're gonna absolutely
love this place
i think we looked it up and it was very
highly rated
and then there was just so much hype
around it and i was just like totally on
board
and so then it was one of the rare
occasions where
i mean we were starving and then we had
a we had drinks
and they were strong drinks and they
brought you and they like mixed
they brought the drinks in this little
they would bring you a glass
of ice and then like the garnishes that
go in a particular drink like say an
old-fashioned so there would be
like an orange peel or something like
that and then they would bring you
the mixed alcohol in a separate
container with a cork on it
and you take that cork out and pull pour
it into your thing now again the old
fashioned yeah
this if you really think about that it's
just kind of an easy way to mix drinks
ahead of time so it makes it easier on
the bartenders
but again because i fully buy into the
hype
i think i say things like oh it's in a
little container
this is awesome and that's the
the thing i remember is getting a little
drunk and then the food coming out and
being
absolutely the star you want to be and i
you know i i just don't
i never i never drink
i just don't drink that much and when i
drink it's
i don't know it's i don't have a great
experience well i think that's
drinking very exceptional well drinking
in the context of great food
is when i'm into the concept the idea of
like hey let's just sit around and drink
a bunch of beer or something like that
or like i'm just sitting around and sip
whiskey i'm kind of like i can take it
or leave it
but if you give me some really good wine
with some really good food
or there's like really good mixed drinks
cocktails with really good food
that there's just something magical
about that you may not feel great
afterwards but in the moment you feel
incredible you had the
and we had good company there was lots
of i mean we were in a strange land
first time i had ever been to london and
we were you know it was we were having a
good time we were we were trading
stories we were trading laughs and
the wait staff were like along for the
ride
so i think that has to be the most
if you isolate the just the meal
it it i think it's my top so much it's
never gotten any better for me it's like
because christy and i took lily back to
london it was just a few weeks later i
talked about it on this podcast and we
went back there
and it and we went to the second
location in between the two
uh i don't know if you call them acts or
whatever it is the two different
there's the first play in the second
play for the harry potter play
so we went in between the two and it was
uh
the food i i built it up for them and
the food was just as great i mean i i
can't wait to go back at the company
well so when i went back to london i
also went with my family we went to the
same location that we did
with everybody before and this
we it was incredible but when four
people
eat you don't get as many things the
thing that made that first time so great
is the fact that it was the first time
yeah and the group was so big that you
ended up getting when you eat indian
food
you want to you you want to taste
everything you want the buffet
experience
when we went back we were like we got to
pick like two two main course things and
it just wasn't the same
you know it was good but it wasn't the
same i mean i was trying to think of
other i mean we've
we've had the privilege of traveling to
so many places
i was asking christy to help me remember
and she was like when we went to
australia
you went up to brisbane you and rhett
and jenna went up there
for the for the one tour stop and i was
like
yes we walked we basically walked all
the way across downtown brisbane because
we only had a few hours
so we kind of did our own walking tour
and we found ourselves that this
do you remember what it was it was
called like
cigar pizza oh yeah yeah yeah remember
how good
the logo than the guys look like me and
you yes right
yeah and it was i mean it was it we were
eating at a weird time so there wasn't
anybody there
but the there were so many good meals in
australia though why would that why did
they call it
the pizza was like it was rolled up it
was rolled up like a cigar
and they had these like comments it was
a glorified pizza roll but it was
very really really good because i cuz
one of the things that comes to mind for
me
is first of all almost every meal
while in australia was good i do
remember uh that mr was it mr wong's
is that the name of the place that was
in sydney that was a giant
oh yeah chinese restaurant um
and we said at that giant table here's
why that meal
wasn't as good as it could have been
because we got in a fight well
because kids were there oh you don't
remember the fight well we got into a
fight yeah because
christy thought that i was trying to
order for everybody when i was just
really
i was just like i'm throwing out
suggestions and christy felt controlled
i think at the
at that moment um yeah i i i could see
her side because i think i was on it
[Music]
that's hilarious though cause you were
so excited and you were like
let's order this and let's order this
and we were just talking about it yeah
it wasn't like it was as opposed to what
you want it was like ordering with the
waitress
you were talking about i was like this
looks good let's get this
this looks good and you're and christy
was like well hold on a second i haven't
even read the whole menu
and i was like okay
but and it should have just been
everything that's mentioned we're going
to order
but there was some that was my
expectation my instinct was that it was
like why don't we get
every single thing that everyone wants
right but that wasn't so i started
naming things that
and i knew that's what was happening
because you know
we go you and i go to places all the
time but then it was
yeah if if the interpretation was oh
he's
he's ordering for the table but that's i
understand
that that's not why i don't it wasn't
then the kids the kids really screwed it
up the kids
kids they have to be taken into account
it's like well i don't know if i like
dunk
you know what i'm saying it says like
listen we're here
we're at one of the best chinese
restaurants in the world by reputation
get the peking duck and quit complaining
about it i don't think i ate any of that
but i didn't complain about it right but
it's just like
you know i think that a general openness
of every single member of the party
is part if you're going to go to a place
like that i think that's the key to
enjoyment and
children assume children are just not
open they had a big experience
and i didn't really love that but i
tried it and then i was like okay that
one thing's not for me
right um
okay well let's move on where else did
we go i
i do remember remember we went to austin
with stevie
and we ordered that huge tomahawk
that was it the steak wasn't that in
austin yeah it was a
uh it's like a huge beef it was a
japanese
meets texas food so it was
all in the style of japanese traditional
food
but done with the meats and the sides
that you typically would enjoy in texas
so the fusion restaurant
that there was a lot of buzz about i
can't remember the name of it but it was
really really good and i remember
talking to
th the trick that we had was you make
friends with the
with the waitress or waiter waitress in
this case and like we were just
we were like you know we're just
visiting we heard about this place we're
excited about it
what you know tell us what is exciting
and then she went through some things
and she was like but and she could tell
from our vibe it was like but you need
to get
this thing she like really sold us on
this like special
huge tomahawk i mean look like a piece
of a dinosaur
it's about the experience listen and
that's why i say
i know listen if you go
and i'm just saying because i know that
there's people who are resistant to
trying new things
but like when you go to a place that's
known for a thing
even if it's a thing that you don't
think you would like or you don't
traditionally like
free yourself towards the experience
open yourself
towards the experience of that new thing
because i think it will make your life
better and i will guarantee you will
make everyone else's lives who you're
with better
just you know you know i mean i
i i understand
that's not directed at you it's not
directed at you
it seems like it could have been
directed at me but
no because you you try you try things i
i do understand
that like when you're in it when you're
having a meal and this should be fun
it's like
you you want to keep negativity
if you have a negative thought keep that
to yourself you know if you're ordering
things to share or whatever because i
love sharing things i love trying
different things i don't like
i don't like committing to a plate like
it's
it's interesting that i'm picky but i
also like to share because i don't like
to commit
right um and i've been rewarded enough
to just give more things to go so it you
know it's happened over time
uh i don't think shaming helps but
i'm not did that you may have taken it
as a shaming i'm saying
open yourself up to the experience
because it you will have a better time
don't deprive yourself of that
experience that's my main point
i agree with that truly mythical know me
twitter handle dink kneel okay
uh one year visiting family in china i
was around 10 years old
we were sat down for a meal entirely
made up of plates of bugs
and served warm liquidated sweet corn
as a beverage i'm a picky eater picky
i'm a picky eater i'm a pickier eater
than link is so you can imagine my 10
year old self was
not having it hashtag ear biscuits
yeah again as a kid it's just like i bet
it wasn't a plate of bugs
i mean but i bet in in their
memory i could see how as a 10 year old
it like comes across that way
right but i mean if there's bugs on the
plate there's bugs on the plate i mean
it's
there's not much mistake in that well
and the thing is is that
we've eaten so many weird things but it
has never hardly ever been in the
context of
a restaurant or uh a meal with somebody
it's on the show
and when you we've eaten lots of bugs
and testicles and
hot peppers and all that stuff and while
those are memorable experiences
some of them more than others like the
hot peppers it's kind of hard to forget
right
you don't get the same
it's memorable for you as a viewer i
think
but for us all the weird things that
we've eaten kind of just
it all blends together there's not
there's very few moments
that stick out in my mind it's like when
you make that live beetle
i think was that the episode that shea
mitchell was there for
yeah and we also were like we didn't
know what was gonna happen
and all of a sudden you're eating this
live beetle i'm like well hey people are
gonna be mad about this
because you're eating a live animal yeah
uh and we probably shouldn't be doing
that and b
like okay this is especially nasty so i
assume that that
stands out in your mind i wonder if like
guy fieri
remembers all of the diners drive-ins
and what is it dunkin donuts whatever
the other thing is here's why here's
what i don't think he does and this
remembers all of the
this is why we don't no way right
because your attention is divided when
you are
primarily in an entertainment mode like
when we eat something on gmm
we're not eating it to experience it and
enjoy it i mean i try to be as present
as possible
but really we're trying to be a conduit
for entertainment and we're trying to
you know like the camera's there even
think about when we did the rib tour in
memphis to find like the best ribs and
we
were thinking about the final product
you're not just thinking about the ribs
in the moment
yeah and um i think we made the right
call about who had the best ribs
i remember by the end there's also this
thing about like
eating on camera you have to eat on
camera when it's time to you know on
camera and it doesn't matter if you're
hungry or not like
we we've actually you know we've looked
we finished
recording episodes and saying you know
what this was scheduled at a difficult
time
uh in the day for for us to record
because we weren't hungry
like um there's certain will it episodes
or i mean in
any of those episodes it's like right we
try to manage
our stomach so that we can actually be
hungry
so it's easier to to actually be
enthusiastic about things that are
amazing
and by the time we got to that third um
what was it called central barbecue
which is the best one
we were hungry again but i think we gave
we were not as hungry
short shrift to uh we're not as hungry
as the uh
the owner assumed we were because that's
actually a pretty memorable meal because
we sat down
yep and we filmed the episode which
involved eating the ribs
and eating some beans and then
we were like well we got to go back to
wherever we were going
um but he but we've got a little time
and he's like well
i want you guys to taste everything and
so it was
me and you and stevie casey ben is that
who the crew was
uh and nick came nick was there and i
think there was at least two more people
so
we sit down at this table
and uh the guy who runs central barbecue
i can't remember his first name now
brings every sing every single thing
that they serve
every single drink that they serve so
like he brought us a bunch of beer i was
like oh god and
annie brought us multiple desserts and i
ain't complaining but i
you know we had to take a lot to go
because i mean the crew was hungry
and i i wanted to try everything but i
just couldn't do it
it was very difficult this is coming
from a guy who can eat until he
thinks he's going to faint there was a
series of responses that i did not
expect
yeah this was it totally makes sense but
i did not know it was gonna happen
so let's let's alternate these there's
four of them
okay sarah holcomb
says for moms it is whatever is given to
you
after delivery after my first delivery i
was given a plain turkey sandwich
applesauce and graham crackers and
peanut butter because it was late
it was the best sandwich ever after
eating nothing for 12 hours and
delivering a baby
georgina gio georgie said
post 18 hours of labor and giving birth
after the epidural wore off
the best chicken fried steak country
potatoes and pancakes of my life
stephanie acidic yarn one one eight
i had a bowl of chili and a hamburger
after my daughter was born
and was allowed to eat again it had been
a minute i had a c-section
from the hospital so that was in
parentheses to eat again
from the hospital cafeteria best burger
of my life
i've yet to have a meal hit me that hard
and finally amanda martinson for me it
was the first meal after
giving birth to my daughter labor for 26
freaking
hours after the dust settled is that
yeah i don't remember there being a lot
of dust it depends on how long the baby
is in utero
after the after the dust settled my
husband went and grabbed my favorite
food from
whataburger for me that was the best
meal of my life
and my first meal as a parent i think
that might be what it takes to make
whataburger good is
i like whataburger the texas joint
oh no i'm getting i'm sorry so much crap
about that i was thinking about fat
burger
yeah yeah i don't like what a burger we
don't like water burgers sorry i mean
but they're texas you've got all kinds
of great things we've established this
but whataburger is not the thing you
should be leading with
um and i mean they're they're talking
about like
hospital cafeteria food being amazing
which
yeah if you've been through that ordeal
and you know christy had three
c-sections i just i don't recall
i'll have to ask her if uh if
if she was starving i think that i
i definitely remember when we found out
we were pregnant uh with lily and gonna
be parents
first of all we but we both took a nap
but then well uh when we started going
in for like
her checkups and her ultrasounds and
stuff we would always eat at chick-fil-a
because it was
the only chick-fil-a that we had access
to
up in kerry was was next to that so like
that became our thing oh we get to go to
chick-fil-a
and that was uh those are those are
memorable
meals for us when it's like you know
just preparing to be a parent
and eating some eating some fried
chicken
with extra pickles in her case but i
don't remember after pregnancy
i don't recall it does make me think of
you know i i definitely can't understand
if you've if you've gone through this
ordeal and you
you know you you haven't eaten it it
does
trigger the memory which is basically
not related at all of like
in college when we would uh
we would fast do you remember this and
not for health reasons this was like for
spiritual
reasons yeah that we would uh you know
they would say you know what take a
take a day or a few days to fast there
was a
there was at least one time where i said
i'm gonna take a a seven day fast
well when you tell a bunch of zealous
college students um about a spiritual
practice like fasting
and and challenge them to do it i mean
our personality is that well
okay well like i'm gonna do this for
longer than you asked me to do it
yeah right so yeah i do i do remember
going for a week in college but i think
it ended up being five days i don't
think it would be seven days very
irritable but i do remember thinking
um i i but by the way i think there were
there were benefits to it but i don't in
terms of
you know it kind of puts things in
perspective it definitely puts
your your relationship with food
in in perspective uh yeah i think it's
just your dependency like your actual
dependency on
on food to survive and you can run that
through a spiritual grid and
gain some uh meaning from it i think
there are many other
things that you can you you can benefit
from spiritually that i don't think that
i did
in terms of making it as you say a
spiritual practice
you know it was more of an experiment
for me
i think where i just got very angry
and irritable that i was doing it but i
do remember
because sometimes we would do it at the
same time we'd do it with our roommates
and like we would get fixated on okay
this is when we're all gonna break our
fast it's gonna be at
six o'clock on friday night and we're
going to go to the golden corral
which by the way if you fast on a
regular basis you know
this isn't how you break your fast
you're supposed to especially the longer
the fast the more gentle the break right
so kind of ease back into it golden
corral does not
ease you in ease is not a word
associated with the only thing easy
about golden corral
is how easy you can fill up another
plate exactly
do you remember that though because
there was they had a
they had a steak and shrimp night at
golden corral and i think maybe it
wasn't friday but we would time our fast
to end
on that night i remember this now that
you're talking about it so we could go
eat a bunch of
like oddly mediocre
steaks yes like i don't know what part
buffet
seems like it was rejected from what you
could get at the grocery store i
i don't i don't recall having like any
difficulties from that decision
you know it's just glorious it was back
when your body could take anything you
completely punish yourself and
there were no consequence but i mean
the thing is is that now i mean i'm not
saying that there's still there's not
still spiritual reasons to fast but like
since then they've they've come out with
all this research about how beneficial
fasting is in general just for health i
mean it's a the whole intermittent
fasting thing
all this crazy stuff that happens to
your body when you fast and like the
cell
rebirth and how it cuts down to
inflammation and all this stuff it's a
you know it's one of the most beneficial
things that you can do for longevity
but last time i did it i hurt my back
and i think they're connected but i
won't even go into why that's the case
long story but it has to do about cell
regrowth and
people with disc issues and there's some
research that suggests that
the renewal process can actually screw
something up in your back and that
happened to me last time i tried to do a
day a one day fast
so i don't know if i'm gonna do it
anymore
stannah u.s said the first meal i ever
made in my first apartment
on my own was amazing i made a grilled
cheese sandwich with white bread
velveeta cheese and butter i opened a
jar of pickles and sat on the floor in
front of my tiny tv
best grilled cheese of my life yeah so
like
meals to commemorate an occasion
uh especially the you know when we moved
in our the creative house we made
we made the vlog about going to
wienerschnitzel
and then coming back because there is
something about that first meal
i can picture my first meal in
the houses that i lived in do any of
those stand out for you
no i can't i mean the only thing when
this made me think about
the um
when i started cooking for myself when i
when i moved into
the apartment that i lived in after you
got married and i you know i got that
new apartment with with some guys
and because when we all lived together
with me and you and greg and tim we
would
cook we've talked about this many times
like a hamburger helper and we would
split it four ways
and those are some memorable meals yeah
like literally it would be the whole
skillet which is hamburger helper by the
way for
you know like 19 year old dude this is
not enough food i mean
i could easily have eaten a whole
hamburger by myself and you should have
eaten at least a half that's why i would
say in a quarter and we would cut it
like a pie
and then give each well the one that we
cut as a pie
was the one that was supposed to congeal
their
hamburger helper has all kinds of
different like form factors and one of
them
is the one that congeals into like a
disc yeah
and the other ones are just like a pasta
and meat together
the one you're i specifically remembered
that one
i don't remember what it was called but
we could cut it into fourths and you got
this just this
fourth of a pan yeah and i was still so
hungry
after we were done with it so i remember
that but i also remember
when i started cooking for myself in my
other apartment i had
i don't know i just have a tendency to
just jump into things with
no expertise or no ability no point of
reference for it and this is before the
internet so i
definitely my mom never taught me how to
cook i never asked
so i remember i had this thing where i
would
take chicken and cut it up and take
onions and cut it up
peppers and cut it up and like saute it
together
and then pour barbecue sauce
into the pan okay and make like a
barbecue sauce and chicken onion and
pepper
soup and then put it over enough
barbecue sauce to make a soup
yeah and then put it over pasta oh god
that sounds nasty
yeah it is i'm sure it is i mean it
tasted good over over noodles huh and i
made this
meal for jessie like
the first time she came to my apartment
she she seemed to like it
[Laughter]
so i remember those very misguided not
following a recipe not having any idea
what i was doing
meals uh here's a weird one
to end on pigeon tante pigeon
uh most memorable meal an edible
painting together with a few other
people
what a famous dutch cook combined all
kinds of different tastes
and structures in the form of a large
painting
after she made it we all together had to
scrape with special crisps
etc the painting empty this is a
phenomenal idea it doesn't sound
like it would be satisfying to taste i
don't think it's yeah i don't think this
is about that
um i hope not i think it's i mean maybe
it was good it depends if it was like a
bean dip it might be good like if it was
like a seven layer bean dip and you had
nachos it would be good
um but i think this is about common
experience and kind of like working
together and doing this meal in this
weird way
this reminds me of and i think i talked
about it on something
but a few years ago jesse and i for a
valentine's day or something we went to
i told you about this went to this
art installation at this museum yeah
yeah
and they had curated this 12-course meal
that corresponded to the specific art
that was in this installation
so like draw your attention to a piece
of modern art of some kind
and then you would eat it and then you
would eat the meal that corresponded to
it now
it was and i ha and it's this is
difficult for me because i tend to be
you know a little too linear in my
thinking sometimes
and so it's difficult for me to just let
my guard down and just i'm actually
better at it than i was just a few years
ago but let my guard down and be like
this is crazy and that's the kind of the
point this is
totally subjective what does this piece
of food
actually have to do with this painting
and the connections that are being made
but nothing right it's crazy but and
there was also the meal where they
the the chef had this tendency to take
there would be some weird sort of meal
taste of something because it's 12
courses and then there would be a
hardened disk of a certain material
a certain ingredient that was
complementary to this thing and it would
like have this disc on top and you would
break it with a spoon and it would like
break over and then you would eat it
and so there was like this sort of like
deconstruction thing happening with your
food
and also the lighting was changing and
they were projecting
um art onto the ceiling and you were
also sitting at a
one very long table with everyone else
who had paid for this experience and you
were supposed to like bring your own
drink
this is the one where you had to run get
the yeah you told us we had to run
yeah yeah and then you and you would
like get to know people
because it was so
different and weird it just became it's
a meal i'll never forget
and but it but again do is it the taste
of the food that i remember
no it's the presentation it's the
experience
and the way that somebody decided to
make it happen so
i don't imagine this painting tasted
great but
and so if you go into the experience
thinking that like man i'm because
sometimes you go into experience and
you're like i'm really hungry
like sometimes you're going to it's like
a party or something like that and
you're like man i'm hungry and i haven't
eaten dinner
i hope they satisfy me you know will
there be meatballs
and if you don't get satisfied you get
mad so
maybe if you're going to do a an
experiential meal like this you should
like
you know eat it eat a grilled cheese
sandwich before you go just
or have one in your pocket right just be
ready to be ready for reinforcement so
you won't judge the experience too much
well that was fun going down memory lane
well i have one like i have one last
thing i got yes you got you didn't this
is out this is a famous story i probably
told it before
uh but it remains the most rememberable
meal to be
one of the most memorable meals of my
life
and that was uh when mama nell came over
for christmas dinner now
we had gone to mom and dale's house for
christmas
in georgia uh what felt like many times
growing up i don't know
and um
we had always gone to her house and she
very rarely came to
visit us where we were at like we would
go down to georgia to see her yeah
um but then after pop died
you know she came up and was living in a
retirement home in north carolina that
was just like a mile down the street
from us
and so she would come over quite often
in those last few years and i remember
christmas dinner and i'm like so excited
like even as a kid
i mean you know i'm this way now but i
was it was just so funny because my kids
are not like this
as a kid i got so excited about food
i got so i can never remember
a point in my existence where i didn't
get
super amped up about a meal that
somebody was about to serve me
and if it was like a significant meal
like christmas dinner i was like i know
mom's gonna make this
this this this this and i would think
about it and get so amped up about it
and i would like
eat so much food so i'm like
just getting to the place where i'm
really enjoying christmas dinner
and uh again this was towards the end of
mamanelle's life and she
i mean she just you know she was very
old at this time
she didn't participate much in the
conversation
and she also didn't eat very much so
they would make her
a really small really small plate and
she would
she was eating and then all of a sudden
like i mean again she's not
participating in the conversation but
she definitely participated
in getting all the attention on her when
she just threw up on her plate
she just and i'm just like sitting
across from her and i just see it come
out and land
on all the there wasn't a lot of food on
our plate like i said
and i'm just like it made me
mad and it was selfish to get mad oh god
you know it may i got mad at her because
she screwed up
my she was choking on food and she i
don't think so
i don't know i don't think she was
choking i think she just was
you know she was just old man
regurgitated yeah she was just old and i
feel
bad to this day and first of all no one
was like
ah mommy now like no one did that
everybody was helpful and they're like
are you okay
and everything you put in my mind i
thought you were gonna say and i just
went right back to eating
uh i'm pretty sure i did end up
finishing eating but
the it it was never the same after that
it wasn't
i mean maybe next year but like that
meal because i had seen the ingredients
that i was enjoying like come out of my
grandmother and go on to the plate
and so it just changes everything at
least i didn't go on your plate
that would have been yeah that i
couldn't have taken that i couldn't have
taken that it was a cross it was across
the way and i don't think there was any
splatter
oh man so that was a memorable yeah
that's never that's never happened to me
man
um you can only you can only hope i got
a recommendation for you if you're if
you're interested
in it it's my turn to give a wreck now
um
everything's being delivered to us we
got a box problem at the house
and like after months and months of
trying to break down boxes and get them
into the recycling can yeah
and my my uh my box cutter was falling
apart
hold on so you don't i've assigned this
i've assigned this to lock
as in the past like two years i'm like
lock you're on box
i've i tried and they don't they i can't
get them to do it
how i want it done you got to let it go
man i know they don't do a good job i
didn't i didn't say
he does a good job but if it doesn't fit
then it doesn't get taken away
if it doesn't fit i'll go out and if it
doesn't fit and the way to make it all
fit because there's so much
and again i got one more person in my
house than you do another box
a lot more boxes it's like exponential
so i'm like you know what
i bet you there is a newfangled
like update to the box cutter that i
could get excited about ordering and it
would make it more of a joy
and of course i'm right if you just
search
box cutter on amazon there's this
company called slice that's pushing this
thing out
and it it looks like the top of a cane
like the top of a shepherd's hook
and that part can like hook on your
pocket or
it's an ergonomic handle that then you
can push you push out the blade like you
would a normal thing but then you hold
it in a more
leveraged position yeah and it um you
know
it goes right like the handle itself
goes against the box
too so it helps you keep it at the right
angle and the blade
is ceramic and rounded on the end and it
won't cut you
which is great for me cut the box not
you
yeah it is it is a i mean it costs 19
bucks but it is
it is splendid i gotta recommend
that you get a slice box cutter three
position manual button with ceramic
blade
available at amazon 2191 reviews
can't cut yourself not a sponsor maybe
they should be
yeah it won't um it's just again it's
not a metal blade
it's ceramic it doesn't rust and it
doesn't cut you unless you're really
really dumb
i've not cut myself with it so that's
not an endorsement
i don't know what is okay i've enjoyed
this thing i i order stuff just for the
box
so i can cut it and probably not that's
probably not a good way to be slice
as a reminder next week we will start
with
uh our one year later deconstruction
stories so
stick around here
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best